all right so our second speaker of the
session and then we'll break and have
coffee isn't a session Carlos of the
shesh I think we overlapped at Penn
State for a year - ok roughly but now
he's at Temple so today hotel is about
differentially private finding sample
confidence intervals thank you thank you
everybody this is a long title but you
know basically there are three things I
want to talk about differential privacy
obviously because this is a privacy
workshop I want to talk about confidence
intervals this is something that is very
central in statistical inference and
then the main emphasis is going to be on
how do you do this in finite samples
when you have small sample sizes like
100 200 300 or thousand or five thousand
you know these are considered very small
sample sizes and this is very typical in
social sciences when you don't have a
lot of data but you still want to do
something meaningful good differential
privacy so this is based on joint work
with Silva Don who was my postdoc
advisor so a lot of this was done when I
was a postdoc at Harvard University at
the circus and feel free to stop me in
between if I'm going too fast or if some
of the concepts are not clear I tend to
speak faster when I get excited
generally ok so we'll start with
confidence intervals I'm sure everybody
knows what confidence intervals are this
is just a very quick outline to put us
all on the same page so one of the
central things about statistical
inference is quantifying uncertainty in
the parameter estimates right we don't
just want point estimates we also want
some sort of uncertainty quantification
so that's basically very key very much
central the statistical inference one
way of doing this is confidence
intervals so they're very popular their
building blocks for many more
complicated tasks like linear regression
causal inference or any kind of model
building that you would like to do
confidence intervals are central to
doing this and we all know that if you
give exact confidence intervals they can
compromise privacy because you know they
you know that you know if you release
too many confidence intervals that are
exact
you can reconstruct the data in fact if
you just give me one confidence interval
I can figure out the mean which is in
you know the center of the confidence
interval so there are people have shown
what kind of you know privacy
compromises you can get by using
accurate confidence rules so the
question for this talk is how do you
estimate valid confidence intervals by
valid I mean the confidence intervals
that give you the right coverage
whatever is advertised and I'll define
what coverage means in a little bit
under the constraint of differential
privacy so we'll be doing both pure and
approximate differential privacy and we
want to get a valid confidence interval
so that's the goal for this talk okay
all right so let me start by setting up
the problem statement we are going to be
in the simplest possible world
throughout this talk and you will see
that even in the simple selling there's
a lot of things that need to be done so
we are going to be in the setup where
everything is one-dimensional we have n
data points they are all coming from a
normal distribution with mean mu and
variance Sigma squared that's the
assumption throughout the talk okay as
simple as it can get and you're also
going to make us life easier for the
purposes of this talk and assume that
Sigma square is known of course the
results that we have worked for Sigma
square are known as well but I'm going
to this focus on the case where Sigma
squared is known what we don't know is
the parameter mu that's the mean
parameter and we are going to assume
that mu lies between an interval - R&R
without privacy this is not needed but
with privacy we will see that this is a
assumption that we need to make so sorry
Sigma squared is known but still you
need to keep it private or something
right so in this case Sigma squared is
known from the top you know a everybody
knows it this is the idealized setting I
mean yeah in reality you don't know what
Sigma squared is you need to keep that
private as well so we have algorithms
for that situation but for the top I'm
going to assume that somebody told you
what Sigma squared is okay all right so
what is a confidence interval here the
formal definition and alpha level
salon differentially private confidence
interval for the parameter mu is a
randomized interval so it is going to be
a random interval because of privacy it
has two sources of randomness one that
is coming from the data and the other
one that is coming from the privacy
mechanism so it's a function of two
quantities the first requirement is that
this estimator should be epsilon
differentially private that's the
privacy requirement the second
requirement is that it should have the
right coverage so what the statement is
telling us is the probability that the
true parameter lies inside this interval
should be at least 1 minus alpha for all
meal so this is basically the you know
95% confidence interval or the 95
percent guarantee that you think about
here we are requiring it to be 1 minus 7
okay and we want this to be true for
every n not just asymptotically not at N
equals infinity we want this to hold for
each finite n that's the goal that's the
finite sample part this is clear the
definition probably everybody knows this
already but you know now this is very
easy if I only need to have these two
requirements can somebody tell me what
is the answer - R - R - R right I can
always just output - R - R and I'm done
it's epsilon 0 differentially private
and it always gives me coverage of 1
minus alpha I don't have to even give
this top right so there is an additional
thing that we want we want an interval
to be as informative as possible which
means we want it to be as small as
possible so let beta be the expected
length of the interval and our goal is
to construct an alpha level epsilon
differentially private interval with the
smallest length so that it's actually
informated right that's that's the area
all right so let's let's see what
happens without privacy without privacy
for all Mew without any you know
restriction and for all n the optimal
interval is x-bar plus or minus Sigma
divided by root NZ alpha by 2 this is
like stat 101 right and the length of
this interval is - Sigma divided by root
NZ alpha by 2 so I'm making sure to keep
all the constants in there because we
care
the constants in this talk alright and
this is going to be our baseline we are
going to try to construct differentially
private confidence intervals that have
land that is as close to this length as
possible we cannot get anything smaller
than this okay so the question is what
is the smallest possible length under
pure and approximate differential
privacy so let's start with our favorite
mechanism which is a Laplace mechanism
and see what happens it does it work you
know what kind of intervals we get and
we'll go from there okay so here's the
setup I have n data points now for me to
apply the Laplace mechanism I need some
bound on the beta so this is I'm
assuming that the data lies between
minus B and B this is a bound that is
chosen by the end user without looking
at the data so this will be an important
point that will come up again later
okay now what do you do this is a very
simple mechanism you take all your data
points you truncate them to lie between
minus B and B which means if anything is
outside B you you replace it with B and
you can't be strung cated data points t
1 up to TIA
so T 1 up to PN are just truncated
points that you get by truncating all
the data to lie between minus b and b
you compute the mean of the truncated
data points let's say that mean is T bar
and then we know that the global
sensitivity of T bar is 2 B by n so we
add a plus nodes proportional to you
know standard deviation to Rho 2 B
divided by epsilon n right this is
everybody knows this mechanism we get a
noisy mean which is T bar plus Z ok so
now the next question is this of course
the output Y bar this is the simple
mechanic next question is you have a
point estimate y bar you want to take
this and construct a confidence interval
from it right so how do you do that so
there are a couple of approaches so the
question here is how do you use Y bar to
estimate a confidence interval or to
perform hypothesis test they are
interchangeable I'm going to you know
use that also as an example because
there's a simulation study so you can
think about at least three approaches
okay the first approaches ignore the
noise and the truncation and pretend
nothing ever happened we did not do any
truncation we did not do any noise
addition so this noisy mean is exactly
same as X bar right this is the naive
approach there's no reason why it should
work but it does work when n is very
very large in particular when n is
infinity this this will be fine
the second approach could be to
incorporate the variance of the noise
added okay so we can be a little bit
more smart and say that we actually
added some noise so we're going to take
the noise addition into account to
construct confidence intervals right and
we can go one step further and say that
we actually truncated and added noise so
we want to derive an approximate
sampling distribution right so I hope
everybody knows what sampling
distribution is what I mean is I just
want to know the distribution of Y bar
by taking into account the fact that I
truncated I added Laplace noise and the
data is coming from a normal
distribution that's what I mean by the
sampling distribution of course the
exact distribution can be very
complicated so I need something that
works for larger these are the three
approaches that we can think about right
we will look at these three sampling
distributions and see what we get so
this is just an example I just did some
simulation studies the first one is
where I am ignoring the noise so the
sampling distribution of Y bar is going
to be normal with mean mu and Sigma
squared by n okay so this is what
happens without privacy but you know we
are pretending that we are not adding
any noise and not doing any truncation
the second idea could be to actually
still use a normal approximation but
increase the variance of the normal
approximation we know that we added the
plus noise so the Laplace nice is going
to increase the variance by this
quantity 8b squared by epsilon squared n
squared and I add that to the normal
distribution so I still use a normal
approximation but the the radiance is
different this is ignoring truncation so
I just notice that that personal access
goes from now minus 40 to 40 so what is
your Epsilon
that's a very good question I don't
remember exactly what Epsilon I use for
the simulation because this was done
like two years ago and never published
anywhere but I'm guessing it's epsilon
is probably around 0.5 I most of my
Epsilon's are like less than 1 in all of
these things so this by the way is so
large because B also plays a big role
and this is basically saying that now
your variance is really large which is
the right thing so this is actually the
right approximation yeah
that's a good question the third
approximation could be so this is still
an approximation but I could use a
normal Laplace approximation so it's a
convolution of the normal distribution
and the Laplace distribution and you can
go one step further and use a truncated
normal laplace convolution which I am
NOT talking about here because you are
truncating so the truncation gives you a
truncated normal distribution and then
you're adding Laplace noise that that's
the exact distribution if your data is
coming from norm there's not much of a
difference between the normal laplace
and the truncated normal laplace okay so
these are the three sampling
distribution that you can use to
construct a confidence interval all
right now we are not going to look at
confidence intervals but we will just do
a small summation study on hypothesis
tests to see how things work out because
confidence intervals require you to keep
track of the coverage as well as the
length it's a little bit tricky I'm just
going to focus on hypothesis testing
okay so we will be testing the following
hypothesis that the mean is coming from
zero versus the alternate that it's not
so it's a two sided hypothesis test we
are going to basically generate n iid
random variables from the standard
normal distribution and then we are
going to release the differentially
private mean using this mechanism that I
described above okay I don't remember
exactly what the bound was but I think I
chose the bound to be around three the
value of P I don't know but as I said I
did this two years ago and then you
compute a p-value based on all these
three sampling distributions okay now
what are we looking for we are going to
repeat this process many times to get a
boxplot
under the null hypothesis we expect the
p-values to have an approximate uniform
distribution which means our test is
doing the right thing if it's a
approximately uniform
solution if it is not then it's not
doing the right thing okay is the
simulation study clear all right so
these are the results so I'll go over
the results one by one on the x-axis I
have the four methods that I described
earlier the first one is a non private
method and then the remaining three are
the private methods that we use based on
the three approximations on the y axis I
have the p value and then different
colors indicate different sample sizes
as you can see we're going from sample
size of 10 all the way up to 10 to the 5
okay I'm really bad at converting it's
10 to the 5 like a million has six zeros
I've used to like thousands ten
thousands hundred thousand so anyway but
it is close on a log scale so the first
plot is non private as you can see
everything is nicely uniformly
distributed it's working fine so this is
what we are looking for the second box
plot is showing you what happens when
you ignore the noise and just use a
normal approximation and we don't expect
this to work anyway right and you can
see that's what is happening so for
example when n is very small this is
very far from our uniform distribution
the median is somewhere over here the
medium p-value right and even if you
increase n when n is equal to 10 to the
5 you start seeing something that is
working reasonably well you have a
uniform distribution
but until then things are pretty bad if
I use the normal approximation with the
increased variance things are starting
to look reasonable again but it's still
far from a uniform distribution and when
you use the normal applies approximation
you kind of start seeing the right right
things that's going on okay so the model
of the story here is that you need to
take into account the noise that was
added to get the valid inference okay
now this is still all asymptotic so we
will try to do all of this in a finite
sample setting okay so this is the
is this a result of many simulations for
the same sample size because I wonder
what can cause the meme to move why does
it shift it downwards enough to not lose
in the normal approximation in this case
oh the turbo is it is it like an effect
of the fact that you will not that you
can so these are not the plots of the
means these are p-values so are you
expecting you would expect it after you
iterate that you repeat the process a
lot of times that it they might be wider
or narrower but they still should be
around him why are they moving I mean
this is this because of pure randomness
right like you you repeat this process a
lot of times Pierre each sample size yes
so basically for each sample size you
generate a normal sample of size n then
you add noise and then you do this
process many many times so you're not
keeping the data fixed nor you're
keeping the noise addition process fixed
so it's just because of your randomness
that there is a slight variation
neither the data and nor the Laplace
nice is fixed from each simulation to
the other simulation they're basically
changing over time right how about you
things looking the tails that's a very
good question so I think it depends on
which method you're using but you get
very heavy so you you're really getting
a very heavy tail distribution and if
you want to approximate it by a normal
your things will go pretty bad right but
the other two so even this is not very
good in terms of the tails but the
normal plus seems to capture the tails
pretty well yeah actually what I thought
that this is might be overly positive to
the normal approximation because if what
you care about is in the tails that
could really be a film right right I
mean here the sample size is very large
right so when your sample size is very
large the second term is very small and
so the tails also work you get a
reasonable approximation in the tails
but for smaller sample size the normal
Laplace approximation captures the heavy
tails as well right
but the normal approximation is third
one yeah it doesn't look as bad yeah it
could be worse yes in the pants it could
be worse they're not really looking at
the tits
any other questions all right so the
model of the story was ignoring the
noise led to invalid hypothesis tests
which also implies that we got invalid
confidence intervals so what was
happening was we were looking at this
point estimate and from the from going
to the point estimate to the confidence
interval we cannot just ignore the noise
and the truncation process right
sometimes it's okay to do that when you
have a large sample size and you can
argue that the second term is going to 0
and probability so this is just opie of
1 when you have very large sample sizes
but generally in finite samples this is
not going to work as we as we saw okay
so we also saw that we can resolve this
issue by incorporating the distribution
of the noise right so if we incorporate
the distribution of a noise we get a
normal Laplace approximation or a
truncated normal laplace approximation
and if you do this you can show that the
confidence intervals that you get will
look something like this so we can
two things that i want to say here the
first thing is you can obtain an
asymptotic 1 minus alpha confidence
interval so this is still an asymptotic
guarantee and the length of the interval
will be something like this so it's a
constant that's a function of B times
Sigma divided by root n this is also a
function of alpha I'm ignoring alpha for
now and then the second term is
basically a constant a different
constant times B by epsilon n okay so
this is the length of the confidence
interval that you would get if you use
the normal or plus approximation it
doesn't look that bad right if you think
about it so I don't have to give the
rest of this talk if that's the case but
there are still some issues right so
I've repeated that line here again this
was just a explanation of how you get
these things and we know this so this is
the length of the interval that we get
with the normal Laplace approximation so
what are the issues here okay the first
issue is that there is a constant term
there's a constant in the first term
that is a function of the bound B okay
so this is happening because of the
truncation and this is typically chosen
without looking at the data so this is
something that we faced when we were
working at Harvard for the circus we had
all these data sets and people did not
know beforehand you know what variables
they are looking at so they had to
basically choose the bound without ever
looking at the data and you're bound can
be widely off right so there are two
things that can happen the choice of B
is crucial for both length and coverage
so if you choose a very small B you are
truncating a lot of the data points
which means you can cause severe bias
right you can imagine in the extreme
case the user doesn't know anything
about the data and they choose a bound
that leads to truncating all the data
points there's nothing remaining right
so that's the extreme case of course
that's not always going to happen but we
can also expect severe bias which means
the confidence interval will not have
the right coverage probability okay so
you don't want B to be very small so
what can you do you can choose a large B
now if you choose a large B the
truncation problem won't appear right
like you're not truncating as much but
you're adding a lot of noise and that's
going to increase the
a confidence interval so that's bad
either right you don't want that to
happen
so and then third point is basically the
coverage guarantee is only asymptotic it
doesn't work in finite samples so the
point being that in finite samples the
coverage can be pretty bad and it
depends on B epsilon and Sigma and we
are assuming that Sigma is known but in
reality you don't even know Sigma and in
finite samples the length can be 100 or
thousand times larger than what you
would get with the non private line
because of this needing term that's in
the first term of the length of the
confidence interval okay so our goal is
basically so this is not going to work
in finite samples our goal is to try and
get rid of this first constant here so
that we don't get this multiplicative
increase in the length of the confidence
interval and then the second thing is
can we get rid of the B all together can
we do you know anything better than this
that's the question and the answer is
yes of course otherwise I wouldn't be
giving this talk but is the is the is
the problem clear hopefully yeah okay
all right so these are the results we
can completely eliminate the dependence
of the length of the confidence interval
on B of course we are kind of cheating
if you think about it
I'll tell you in a little bit while
you're cheating but we can completely
eliminate the dependence on B and we can
provide a exact coverage for all and not
just N equals infinity so the coverage
will be true for N equals one two three
four five all the way up to infinity for
every possible finite n we get exact
coverage okay now we need to make some
assumptions here and this is what I
meant by cheating a little bit but you
see it's not exactly cheating
so for pure differential privacy you
still have to make an assumption that
the mean parameter lies between minus R
and R it's bounded okay so you might
think that from assuming a bound on the
data I am basically just shifting my
problem - assuming bound on the main
parameter right but you'll see in a
little bit this is a this is a slightly
better assumption the dependence of the
length of the confidence interval is
only logarithmic on R so you can choose
R to be as large as you want and you
still don't pay a lot okay and then the
second point is that for approximate
differential privacy you running
have to make that assumption so you can
actually completely get rid of the
assumption that the mean parameter lies
in some you know bounded domain and
there is no dependence on B as well so
for approximate differential privacy
there is no input that we need from the
end user for constructing these
confidence intervals of course I won't
have time to talk about the algorithm
for approximately and then the third
thing is for pure and approximate
differential privacy you are not making
any assumptions on the range of the data
of course we are assuming that they're
coming from a normal distribution but
they can be you know supported on the
entire real line and we also show that
these are actually minimax confidence
intervals so we have lower bounds on the
length of the intervals and our
estimators match those lower bounds up
to logarithmic factors so we know that
these are reasonably good in terms of
minimax city and all of these results
hold for the unknown variance case as
well but I won't have time to talk about
the unknown variance
okay so these are our results any any
questions so the estimator is actually
very simple I'll go into the details of
how to construct this estimator in a
little bit
oh there's one last point so I also
wanted to say that with some minor
increase in sample complexity we also
obtain intervals that suffer only
additive increase in the length instead
of multiplicative increase so if you you
know I'll explain this in a little bit
but if you remember there was a constant
factor that was being multiplied in the
first term of the confidence interval we
are able to get rid of that constant
factor as well so it's all about
constants basically in this table okay
all right so how do you construct this
optimal estimator I'm just going to talk
about the norm variance case so they're
very to say it's a very simple algorithm
there are two steps in the first step we
are going to estimate a differentially
private range of the data okay so the
user gives us input to the range of MU
they're going to use that and estimate a
range for the data itself that is
differentially private and now we are
going to use this differentially private
range to truncate all the data points
and compute the confidence interval
using this
to Madrid rains so there are only two
steps okay and I'll go over these steps
in a little bit in more details and this
estimator basically depends on the log
of the range of mu so this is optimal
because you can set R to be as large as
you want the dependence is only
logarithmic whereas in the previous case
the dependence on B was linear so that
basically increases the length by a lot
okay and of course this gives us honest
coverage which means for every n we are
getting the 95% confidence interval
coverage so how does this estimator work
it's very simple so assume that so
there's a series of cartoon animations
assume that you know my mu is somewhere
here between minus R & R R is something
that the user had given me and these are
my data points they're all stick figures
okay because there are people and we are
trying to protect some information about
them so I have n data points now in the
first step I'm going to truncate
everything that is lying outside between
minus R and R so in this example these
two people will go away okay so
everything lies now inside minus R & R
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
construct a histogram of size Sigma we
are assuming that we know Sigma so I'm
going to divide minus R to R into blocks
of length Sigma and then construct the
histograms all these people get stacked
up and now I'm going to add the plus
noise so of course you can get negative
guys some of them you know weird things
can happen and now I'm going to pick the
largest bin here the largest noisy bin
which in this case is this guy okay and
next what I'm going to do is I'm going
to take my largest noisy bin and expand
it on both sides by sigma x square root
log n times some constant which i'm
ignoring but if the constants are in the
paper okay and this is going to be my
range so x-min and x-max
is basically the largest bin - Sigma or
root log n and small has been sorry the
largest bin plus Sigma or plugin okay
this is the estimator for the range and
you can show that this is differentially
private and if you have a reasonable you
know
sample complexity this is optimal
dependence you can show that most of the
data points will lie inside this range
so no truncation happens I mean this is
very easy to see right because a maximum
of a Gaussian is approximately Sigma
square root log n that's what is
happening here okay
very simple since you know this Sigma
square you could from the beginning just
avoid you could do the truncation of
data nut at the range R but R plus Sigma
or a few Sigma so you could do that as
well
save this step you could do that as well
but that still will lead to so what
you're saying is instead of doing L plus
or minus square root Sigma log n you
could do R plus Sigma square root log n
you could do that yes but it will still
lead to suboptimal dependence on the
sample complexity okay where you the
reviewer of our paper because the
exactly so what do you mean a new person
comes into the scene like okay you run
the same algorithm I mean if so I don't
know what do you mean by adding another
person but if the person is still
outside this range they will get
truncated if they're inside
so you're doing it realtor yeah so I
don't think this will work in the real
time we didn't think about that like if
you're getting streaming data and you
want to do this I don't think this is
gonna work
yeah that's the only thing so this is
the assumption that all the data is
sitting with you somewhere already and
you're not really doing it in a
real-time setup where you're getting a
new data point each time okay I haven't
thought about it if this is going to
generalize him that self okay right so
sorry did I go ahead too quickly yeah so
this was the this was the estimator for
the range so now once you have the
estimator for the range you can
basically use this to estimate the
confidence interval so you first
estimate the range and then you truncate
all the data points to lie inside this
range and by the properties we know that
probably nothing will get truncated with
very high probability because we are
using a reasonably large range and then
you estimate the mean of this truncated
data point with very high probability
the mean is going to be equal to remain
without truncation and then you add the
plus size to this proportional to the
global sensitivity which depends on the
range that you estimated okay and once
you get be noisy Y bar you want to
construct the confidence interval by
modeling both sources of randomness the
Laplace nice as well as the you know
normal distribution and you're also
taking care of the truncation because
with high probability we're not really
truncating anything so that is also
taken care of in this whole process okay
and you get an interval that looks
something like this it's Sigma divided
by root n Z alpha 1 by 2 plus the second
term is global sensitivity over epsilon
n log 2 over alpha 2 so the second term
is coming from the laplace nice addition
and then the first term is coming from
the normal distribution and if you want
an alpha confidence interval you have to
split your alpha between alpha 1 and
alpha 2 so that you get the right
coverage okay so there are questions on
how to optimally split alphas and things
like that this is okay yeah all right so
you don't have to read the whole theorem
but basically the length of the
confidence interval that you get from
running this algorithm is Sigma divided
by root n plus Sigma divided by epsilon
and log 1 over alpha so this here I am
ignoring the constants we
we want to compare this with minimax
lower bound and this does match the
minimax lower bound of two logs of the
make factors okay
once we do this we'll come back to we'll
put the constraints back in geez about
the statement about logarithmic factors
because that's the only difference you
have an alpha is a logarithm it's so the
original term here is hiding some log n
2 log n yeah right so yeah this we are
making it explicit the dependents I mean
I could have removed this as well and
said that it's Sigma or epsilon and or
Tiller but I wanted to keep that
accessible any other questions all right
so now coming back to the constant so I
don't have time to talk about the
algorithm but if you notice here there's
a Big O in the leading term as well
which we don't want because this can be
a very large constant in fact you can
get intervals that are 100 times larger
than what you would get without privacy
so that's not a good thing so we want to
get rid of the constant here as well and
that is possible with some extra work
you can get something that looks like
this so the first term is 2 Sigma
divided by root n Z alpha by 2 plus a
constant times Sigma over epsilon n
square root log and log what 1 over
alpha ok so if you compare this with the
one without privacy the first term is
exactly the same that you get without
privacy and then the second term is
basically the additive increase that you
get in the length of the confidence
interval so this is good because now we
are not really getting a multiplicative
increase in the length of the confidence
interval okay that makes sense and this
this is not optimal we have a minor
increase in the sample complexity so
this actually doesn't match the minimax
lower bar so this is a question that we
have is this minor increase in sample
complexity necessary to get rid of the
constant terms constant factors in the
first step or is it possible to still
retain the same sample complexity and
get a additive increase it's not clear
yet
okay and of course you know for the
unknown variance case so by the way any
questions about this algorithm I'm
almost done with my talk like do you
have this increase from the minimax I
didn't mention that here but like this
if you notice this sample complexity
term this is what we get from the lower
bound but if you want to get rid of the
multiplicative constant in the first
term I think you get an extra it's not
much but you get like something like log
1 over epsilon or something I don't
remember exactly what it is so the
sample complexity increases slightly the
dependence of the sample complexity on
epsilon is not what we are getting from
the minimax hormones so either we need a
different lower bound or we need a
different algorithm for the aerator okay
all right so the basic algorithm is very
simple and we needed to know what the
variance was for the unknown variance
case you can proceed in a similar way
you obtain a crude estimate of Sigma by
taking paired differences so you take
all your data points you subtract them
and take the absolute value and then you
can run the exact same process to get an
estimate of Sigma star and then you run
the same algorithm by using Sigma star
and all of it works reasonably well so
that's basically what this is saying you
estimate the Sigma star which is a crude
estimate of Sigma and then you pretend
Sigma star is basically the unknown
Sigma and estimate the range and you
also need to add noise to Sigma squared
because you don't know what Sigma
squared is for estimating the confidence
interval and you can do similar things
for two-sample t-tests which are basic
requirements for doing causes infants
okay and you can do further optimization
for finite samples so we we wanted to
get as much optimization possible for
you know real real world situations so
the next set of optimizations that you
can do is instead of truncating at
square root Sigma log n you could
truncate at constant times Sigma so you
also remove the square root log n factor
and that actually works very
in practice and that's what we end up
using eventually in our algorithms so
that's what I'm trying to say the range
estimator has a square root of log and
dependence and you can get rid of that
by actually truncating using some
constant so you will actually have some
truncation in this case and you know you
can also do one more optimization by
replacing the mean with the trim mean so
instead of now computing the mean you're
actually computing a trim mean because
you're doing some trimming and you can
also look at exponential mechanism-based
median estimators and things like that
so these are all further optimizations
that we did for it to work in practice
and these are some results that I wanted
to show based on these optimizations so
I won't go over all of these three
methods but I want you to look at the
x-axis this is the sample size it's
going from 0 all the way up to 100,000
so I split it into two because it was an
exponential thought it was hard to see
in one plot the y-axis is the ratio of
the length of the interval that you get
with and without privacy okay so you get
one interval without privacy and then
you get one more interval with privacy
this is the ratio so this is the
multiplicative increase in the length of
the interval that you get and we want it
to be close to one right one means that
there is no change from the non-private
interval okay and there are three plots
here and there are three different
algorithms that we just described the
best algorithm that we have gives us
something like two times the increase in
the length of the interval at sample
sizes as small as thousand which is a
pretty big deal in my opinion to be able
to do something like this and of course
we are making a normality assumption but
it's you know you can you can apply the
same algorithm for subdivision and other
other assumptions they are generating a
sum and as you increase the sample size
it seems like we are getting closer and
closer to one there's some funny things
going on these algorithms are kind of
overlapping with each other but I didn't
tell you what these algorithms were so
they're based on trimming though they're
not based on the square root log and
Sigma term you need to trim to get
something like this
and you can apply the same thing to
difference of means so in the difference
of means case we have two samples one
from a normal distribution mu 1 Sigma
Sigma 1 squared second one from a
different normal distribution mu 2 Sigma
2 squared they can have different sample
sizes our goal is to estimate a
confidence interval for the differences
so this is a basic building block for
causal inference whenever you are trying
to do causal inference this is like the
average treatment effect so the first
population is basically when you're
treated the second one is when you are
not treated and you're trying to
understand the difference between those
two ok so I just want to show a quick
simulation example that we are able to
get with these algorithms so if you
assume that the MU 1 is 5 and mu 2 is
3.5 and the variances are 1 sample sizes
are thousand epsilon is equal to 0.5 you
get almost 93 percent coverage so it's
very close to the required coverage and
the ratio of the confidence interval
that you get is 1.7 so you're only
increasing your intervals by 70% even
for such small Epsilon's and this is
just an example of how the confidence
intervals look like so these are just
ten random confidence intervals that I
plotted the dashed line is what you get
without privacy and the solid line is
what you get by applying our algorithm
and this is the true mean that you're
trying to basically estimate alright now
in the remaining five minutes I just
want to talk about the basic idea behind
all of this so this was all for
optimizing the constants but this can be
generalized to other statistical
inference tasks and this is basically
what I've been working on for the past
ever since I graduated I guess you know
I don't remember how many years so the
main idea is that if you ignore the
noise you will get invalid coverage okay
and we were able to obtain the right
coverage by carefully modeling the
truncation process the noise from the
differential privacy process and the
data generating process okay and this
idea can be generalized so here's how
the
looks like you know you have a privacy
mechanism and you have your normal
distribution and you want to basically
take into account both of these inputs
when you are doing your inference right
so the way I would like to generalize
this is I call this a likelihood based
framework for differentially prevalent
prints so you start with your population
as always there are little stick figures
and you do some sort of random sampling
to get your sample right and this is
your statistical model so in our case
the statistical model was a normal
distribution you can have a finite
sample inference where there is no
assumption made on how the data was
generated or it could be count models as
in Stephens example you know Stephen
gave a very nice example which can be
thought of as an instantiation of this
framework so what you do is you take
your sample and you add some additional
randomness which is your privacy
mechanism which is represented by Q here
okay and you get a private sample so
this object could be either some noisy
sufficient statistic or some noisy data
or some noisy come okay and what you
want to do is you want to basically
model these two sources of randomness so
that gives us to this object that I call
as the marginal likelihood or the
missing data likelihood the idea is
basically you think of your original
sample is completely missing you don't
have access to it
so you need to integrate over all
possible missing data that you would
have seen and this is the marginal
likelihood integral it's a function of
the privacy mechanism and the original
data as well the good thing is that you
know exactly what the privacy mechanism
is because of a Finchel privacy you know
the parameters of the privacy mechanism
right so you all you need to do is work
with this marginal likelihood integral
or the missing data likelihood integral
okay so here you can think of these
gamma as nuisance parameters they are
known in the privacy case and theta are
your parameters of interest which you do
not know and you can obtain them by
maximizing this this likelihood okay and
everything in my opinion relies on this
margin likelihood every inference that
you want to do with differential privacy
you have to work with this so for
example if you want to do maximum
likelihood estimation you maximize this
guy if you want to compute posterior
distribution as Steven was doing you
basically compute post
distributions by looking at this
likelihood and putting whatever prior
you would like to put if you want to
generate generate synthetic data you use
the same thing and so on and so forth so
any inference that you do you do using
this this this object now of course this
is very difficult so this is easy in
principle but the main problem is this
is an intractable likelihood because
you're summing over all possible missing
data and that can be a very high
dimensional object right so almost all
the techniques revolve around how do you
approximate this object like variation
inference or using MCMC and things like
that okay so people have done this
before
this is not a new idea you know one
approach is whenever you have a
sufficient statistic you can use a
measurement error approach and you can
try to estimate the sufficient
statistics from noisy one so there's a
line of work where this approach was
taken the idea is that you start with
the sufficient statistic you add some
noise you get a noisy sufficient
statistic and you can project it back on
to the space of valid sufficient
statistics that will remove the
measurement error so this avoids dealing
with the intractable likelihood
altogether okay
but this doesn't work all the time so in
the other cases you need to basically
approximate the missing data likelihood
by a surrogate so either you can use
MCMC or you can use variation inference
or you can do parametric bootstrap and
so on and so forth so we have a couple
of examples where we did this and like I
said Steven talked about that in his
first talk where he's doing exactly this
where he's doing MC MC and he also
talked about future work where he is
going to do a variation inference okay
so the summary that I want to say
related to the confidence intervals was
we wanted to get confidence intervals
that are value in finite sample and they
only have an additive increase in length
we were able to do that the big picture
point I want to make in my talk is if
you want differential privacy to work in
finite samples we have to really pay
attention to optimizing constants we
can't just ignore them and not worry
about them and for valid inference you
know simple application ism is not
optimal in many cases most of us know
that we need to basically incorporate
everything that we are doing the
truncation the additional randomness
you know in the finite sample
distribution to get the right inference
and you need to carefully design the
algorithm and inference procedures for
each task so it's not just about
optimizing constants this is a theory
question given any statistical inference
task we need to come up with new
differentially private algorithms that
basically take care of the constants as
well it's not just taking an existing
asymptotic algorithm and trying to you
know optimize the constants in that case
so these are some references that I used
for my talk there are lots I'm just
going to go back and stick under
somebody thank you time for really quick
question or two and you can bother to
drink coffee right so what's what's the
best you you had this sort of two term
expression for the average you don't
have to go back to it but just like that
the if you want the leading term to be
at the right constant
what's the best sort of function of n
it's log n divided by epsilon N 1 log n
divided by epsilon and yeah it's like a
log in over what's necessary right yep
and if you if you try to get rid of the
log n then you will end up getting a
constant at least the way we know right
now you gather you end up getting
constant in the first term but there's
there's no lower bound that says that
that overhead is this we don't I mean we
don't have one yet
it's okay
at the beginning of the presentation
you'll expose the common practice is to
assume that they the days are bounded
for example my DMV you say okay now that
solution is that the need it could be
minus R + 1 right what if I said the
same interval in both in the pokey
what if I you put simple my instead and
thing should I respect that the
performance so you if I understand
correctly then you need to choose only
one
you either bound the data or you bound
the parameters you don't need to do both
I'm saying let's say that I okay and
then I can bound me say in same bound in
both the cases yeah
so the one where you're bounding the MU
will give you better interval just
because the dependence on the bound is
only logarithmic whereas if you bound
the data the dependence of the length of
the interval is linear so even if you
use the same so suppose B is equal to R
the bounding mu will give you a better
confidence interval all right so are we
I think both speakers again we go get
some
[Applause]